[Music]
hey everybody what's going on yep it's
Monday it's another haunting Monday yeah
that means it's it's ghostly time yeah
just sent Sophie back on the air she to
uh dropped her off to the airport she's
on the airplane probably by now yeah
she's probably on the plane yeah did a
bunch of photos on uh Instagram accounts
uh I don't know if there's any of them
on 13 o'clock but you know yeah I don't
know she might have she might have like
put them on Instagram like I saw that
she posted a bunch of them on uh
Facebook that we took
over the weekend yeah because we
actually went out Saturday night too
like to a different place uh and we had
a much better time yeah I didn't have to
beat up the bar
yeah well maybe we'll talk about that on
the Sidetrack show like we just kind of
talked about it no I mean no I mean like
the difference between the place we go
Saturday night like yeah because me and
Sophie were talking about it because
Sophie was like oh this place is much
better and I was like yeah yeah but um
you know what I mean
so yeah that's really special we did
find out like that guy um that guy has
been banned from yeah from mannequins so
you know what I mean if you guys were I
mean that seems like the least they
could do obviously but because he'd
apparently been there before like
because our friend Dave who's here
sometimes uh he went there the next
night looking for him but you know they
said he didn't come back and yeah the
other guys he's welcome back
I mean
I [__] slapped him and he he left so I
didn't even see that guy so he grabbed
your ass well I know that but it's like
uh yeah he was behind that was yeah in
front of his friends too and to be
honest all those kind of like Frat Boys
you know not to be racist or anything
but uh but yeah
it's like I'm racist against Frat Boys
well they all look alike I don't know I
can't tell more for the other so um
all right so uh yeah so I've been going
back through all the lists of Haunting
episodes
and trying to like fill in all the gaps
because I had thought that we had
covered pretty much all the episodes
like in the first four seasons just over
the years because remember we used to do
some like a long time ago but every time
I look at the list I keep like finding
ones that we haven't done that we forgot
about and this one was actually like a
pretty okay episode I think it was kind
of forgotten about it yeah and you know
coincidentally it's called The Forgotten
which made me wish me I forgotten
when did we see
I forgot all about that yeah
[Laughter]
but yeah well the thing about it was
like I but it was a good episode though
and I kind of did we just see so many of
them that you know we think we've talked
about that before and it's funny because
when I was looking at the when I was
making the um the thumbnail like the
actor that was on there I don't think he
was the main guy that played the dad or
whatever but I think he was one of the
people who played maybe one of the
paranormal investigators or whatever
that was the same guy that played the
brother on the Summerwind episode yeah
because I looked at his face in the
picture and I could imagine him like
that whole hypnosis scene from
Summerwind I am strong right that's what
I heard it in my head
so yeah so uh this is another one that
has like some of the same actors in it
and stuff like that now I will note that
there is this is a case where there is a
book about this case I'm not sure who it
was that wrote it I guess it was like a
friend of theirs and I have seen it was
going back a few years though because I
went to the Facebook page for the book
the book is called harvesting shadows
and it's by somebody named um Douglas
burchill burchill
and um so it did have but I I haven't
they haven't posted on the Facebook page
for the book since like 2017. so I'm
assuming and I saw like the the lady
that was you know the the mom on this
episode she was like on a couple
paranormal shows back in the day like I
guess when the book came out no Trey
this this shirt is only available direct
through us I make it myself I got shirts
in stock if you want one just you can
pay through a super chat or something
like that and I'll send you one we got
another one going out tomorrow oh do you
hear that
we got I got two of them coming he was
supposed to place the order with you
yeah yeah three excels yeah it's like
yeah there's two of them yeah I think or
they're both gonna be the Blade Runner
they're Tyrell corporations the Tyrell
Corporation yeah yeah so we got to make
those and send those out and if I don't
think Victor is here but we but your
cookbook went out this morning no good
like I unless you brought it back in you
didn't break back in did you
I have a habit of doing that guys
that's delivery enough well yeah because
I like you know because if you have like
USPS click and ship you know you print
out the the postage and then it's like
Where Are You Gonna Leave it and then
like the mail carrier will come and pick
it up from your house and so I leave it
on the front porch and like one time he
thought it was male so he brought it
back in yeah and I was like uh that was
supposed to go out earlier today you
[__] all up but yeah
well maybe I did say that that sounds
like something I would say but um yeah
Trey said uh oh they're talking about
the little badges he's like I wish it
had stayed green yeah they kind of um I
couldn't decide because I thought it was
kind of neat that like it changed colors
like every month you know what I mean
like it would you could change it every
month
um so I was like well I could just leave
it green but I was like oh let's change
colors I think that would be kind of
cool but I don't know maybe I'll just
make it stay green it doesn't really
matter I guess I just liked that it was
like that it could change colors all
right so uh so like I said this is from
season three this one
episode six
and this one took place in Salt Lake
City Utah
and uh there is a slight Mormon because
I mean it's Salt Lake City Utah I think
it goes for Mormon yeah it's warm I
guess you know Mormon ghost yeah my
Mormons have souls
not like redheads
[Laughter]
it's true we don't yeah but um yeah I'm
a natural redhead in case you didn't
know but um but yeah so I don't know
like I don't really know I didn't um had
the book been free I probably would have
at least skimmed through it like because
you know I have that Kindle unlimited
thing and like sometimes ebooks are free
like you can read for free without
subscription but this one was not this
one was seven dollars and so I was kind
of like can't really afford that and I
said and even if I did pay for it I
wouldn't have had time to read the whole
thing so I'm not really sure if the
stuff they came came up with on the show
like for who these ghosts were and
whatnot
um is legit because
it happened such a long time ago that
you could pretty much say anything you
wanted to I'm not saying it didn't
happen I mean it could happen sure but
yeah if it goes goes so far back in the
past it's it's it's ripe for Tom Foolery
going on inside
and shenanigans yes
and they do things chicory pokery yeah
I'll go back and do [__]
interpolations into the kit into the
case yeah so you never can tell yeah but
you just gotta take it at face value and
compare it to other cases that are more
credible and see if the patterns kind of
match that's usually what I do usually
there's if it's a good case the the
order of things and the pat you can see
a pattern of that'll fit a certain kind
of known phenomenon be it haunting or
Poltergeist or you know
tomfoolery if if there's a whole bunch
of [__] in there that [__] is not
that really parapsychologists haven't
noticed especially back back in the day
back in the 60s than something it's
suspect to me you know if there's a
mixture of [__] reported phenomenon
that tend not to go in the same kind of
a [__] case you know
I propose nothing I just thought how
funny would it be if your wrestler name
was Tom Foolery Ross yeah
well that works yeah for some reason I
thought of like wrestling game but yeah
yeah so um
poolery Rock but yeah so Salt Lake City
Utah this one seemed more like this one
didn't really have any Poltergeist kind
of things and also refreshingly didn't
have any demon [__] yeah which is this
one of the few that it's like because
even the ones that just have ghosts and
even have like kindly ghosts are always
like oh but then there's a bad one who's
like demonic or whatever this one has a
bad ghost but not a demon so I thought
that was kind of I remember thinking
that you're gonna go through it again
and it'll remind me but remember at the
time watching it it kind of made me
think that it might have just been what
I what I like to call a bad house
yeah it sounded like a bad house yeah
Sophie watched it with us actually we we
all watched it last night because the
special effects are pretty good for you
know that oh yeah
pretty good for an old for something old
funny man 30 one year old [__] treat
and everything like it's like it's old
well it is
and then uh she goes I remember when I
was a little kid I watched these and I
was like
yeah I guess so I remember well yeah
they used to be so scary you watch them
now they're not scary yeah yeah
yeah I mean because these what season
three was I think 2008 maybe 2008 or
2009 something like that which doesn't
seem like I mean it doesn't seem like
that long ago but I guess it kind of is
so um this story in particular
of the forgotten that took place in 2003
well kind of like a three-year span I
think from like 2003 to 2006.
so we're following a couple and they
actually did apparently use their real
names because they put the real faces on
there not like the last week when they
were in Shadow and their names are April
James and Matt Brody I think they said
so they were kind of like engaged or
whatever
and uh April has two sons I guess from a
previous relationship named Chris and
Brian who are 13 and seven I think Brian
was maybe the young one he was the
younger one I think I don't remember
um Matt is a general contractor
and April works she like manages a
nightclub so she works like a lot of
hours they said she worked like 50 60
hours and always like at night because
it's a nightclub you know what I mean
but they said that they um you know even
though they didn't see each other much
and everything like that they did
actually for a change like start having
quite a bit of money
and they were like well we wanted to buy
a bigger house and she had always wanted
an old Victorian house that was like her
dream
so they actually find one in the old
section of Salt Lake City I've never
been there so I'm not entirely sure you
know what what it looks like or whatever
but they um they're like pretty much one
of the first ones they looked at April
was like immediately like this is the
house I want um you know we need to get
it now it was you know a Victorian so it
was about 100 years old and it needs uh
massive Renovations so you know but the
guy's a contractor so he's like yeah you
know if you want it we'll get it uh so
they actually leased it with an option
to buy interestingly at this point and I
they made such a point of it that I
wrote it down because I thought it was
going to play into the thing later on
but it didn't but they were like oh it
has a tree swing and I'm like is some
ghost going to be sitting on that later
and I was like tree swing this might
matter like I wrote in the notes spoiler
alert it doesn't matter they never bring
it up again I don't know why they why
they made a point of like mentioning it
but whatever that's why I wrote it down
there I remember that [__] yeah it
didn't mean anything yeah that's what I
mean I thought that they were like
foreshadowing something because I just
saw a little boy swinging in the tree
on the swing that's all
yeah but I well I don't even think they
had that did they
said no they just mentioned that there
was a tree swing in the front yard I was
like okay did they showed a little boy
[__] go in there and oh did they yeah
oh okay I must have been looking down
yeah you see that they showed a little
because I said they're going why are
they telling us to the trip it's like oh
it also has a dishwasher I saw a little
boy swinging on it and you couldn't
figure out where he went
I thought that was last week's episode
although like I said I'm I'm writing
notes at the same time and I'm trying to
like glance up and watch everything and
like write at the same time so I might
have like it might have been quick and I
missed it I don't really know
so basically what they decided to do
because this house needed so many
Renovations Matt is gonna and his crew
are gonna work on the renovations while
the rest of the family is still living
in the old house essentially
so he's like we started he's like I
started fixing up the third floor
because I figured you know I could stay
up there you know we could live up there
if we had to like while I was working on
the lower floors so he basically got
that done like first of first
now while he's in there on the third
floor doing the stuff
he's measuring like a closet like a
closet door or something for whatever
reason
and the lights in there start flickering
and then he notices in there there's
like this little he said it was like a
two foot by two foot opening like in the
back wall not an opening but it had like
a little door it was with a little hatch
and stuff like that and it actually this
was pretty effective because what they
did and I don't know if this is how it
really happened or not but when he first
looked into the closet there was like
nothing in there but then there was like
a coat I think it was a coat that was
like hanging like on this back thing and
it looked almost like a person but
enough not like a person that it was
like really creepy and like uncanny and
I think they did a good job of that like
whoever put that coat there I thought it
was like good it was like creepy looking
and then you saw that it was a Coke
because he like moved it aside so he
finds this little opening and he's like
oh what's this so he opens it and crawls
in there because you can just walk in
you had to crawl in there because it was
little
so it was essentially this hidden room
and it had like all these kids drawings
like on the walls like little paintings
and stuff you know butterflies and [__]
like that like all over the walls
and then he's like and on the other side
of it there was another though like a
full-size door now on the um on the
recreation they showed it was like a
door like with glass panes almost like a
front door but I don't know if it was
really like that or not and he's like
and then it looked like there was
another door like just past that you
know what I mean a wall or yeah it was
like a weird it was like nailed shut it
was vague yeah this like this door was
like I think he said it was nailed shut
but there was like kind of like a so it
was almost like a little bitty like
Suite of two little rooms that had been
kind of like hidden behind this closet
essentially the way they showed it
looked like like somebody had made a
secret room yeah and had concealed a
door yeah but I can't really picture any
that you know what I mean I think what
it really was was an air conditioning
return that's the only thing that an air
conditioning return that you could just
pull out of the wall I mean because that
does kind of look like that yeah and
maybe we have one out right out there in
the hall look like an air conditioning
return you could pull out of the wall
because maybe it wasn't screwed into
place
and then it led into two rooms that had
a door that you could access didn't say
that the other side did they actually
say the other side of the door was
concealed they showed it as being kind
of concealed
yeah it was kind of like you said it was
kind of vague like he crawls into the
thing and it's like there's clearly a
little room in there that like was like
look like a nursery type situation yeah
it wasn't any furniture or anything but
there was like little kids paintings on
the walls and then there was like a
full-size door but he said it was nailed
shut but it had glass panes and like
when he cried the nails out and like
went through it it looked like there was
another room like another small room
like beyond that so it was like two
rooms behind I was getting like in a row
I was getting kind of confused because
yeah me too they're leading you to think
that this was a con two concealed rooms
yeah but doesn't quite say that what it
may have been is that you there was one
room where you had a door all right like
a bedroom and then you hit a door and
you saw it had glass panes or
damn maybe you couldn't open it right
because it had been nailed shut but
there's obviously something behind that
door right and then if you went around
to the other side of the rooms there was
an air conditioning return right and you
could just pull the grill off yeah I
guess yeah I think that's what it was
that might have been that yeah so
technically that's not a concealed room
you know that that room is there because
there's a door leading to it well and
another thing too the way they showed it
in the recreation was that the second
room had a window and the window wasn't
blocked off so I'm assuming you'd be
able to see that you know the sun was
coming in right so you'll be able to see
the window from the outside so it's like
oh well yeah there's obviously a room
there they mentioned this is a Victorian
I lived in a the bad house I lived in
[__] over there in in right outside
in uh right outside
um
Boston it was actually Medford I think
is was the name it was in Medford OR
Arlington I don't remember I think it
was I think it was that was I think it
was Arlington
it um
um we were there for about [__] five
six months that house had a nonsensical
layout too because it made sense at one
time but there had been revisions to the
[__] house and they've knocked walls
down and then added walls but originally
an old Victorian houses layout was just
nonsensical they didn't
you know you had to walk through other
people's bedrooms to get to the [__]
bathroom just [__] like that you know no
hallways just connected rooms
so it may have been a situation like
that just a real old house
the room layout made sense at one time
in the past
before indoor plumbing that kind of [__]
you know it didn't matter if you walked
through other people's houses because
there were other people's rooms because
they were all your relatives
and they were there was they didn't hey
don't mind me yeah they were no
expectation of privacy you know they did
all kinds of weird [__] back then
well like you said I think over the
years too
um you know a lot of them got turned
into like boarding houses or apartments
or something like that so people put in
walls knocked out walls yeah so now it's
like jumble right so now it's kind of
like a jumble of stuff but yeah so he
finds this weird room and then they do a
thing where he's like huh look at this
like weird room or whatever and then
they do like a they did a couple of like
cheap jump scares and this one not gonna
lie like suddenly his wife's like pavon
he's like God damn it like don't do that
you know what I mean so it was that kind
of [__] so Matt's like you know we could
just tear this wall out here and make
this a humongous walk-in closet
and she's like yeah yeah that's a good
idea let's do that
so then he's in there another day I'm
assuming this is another day and he's
like working on the house again and he
has like a I guess he has like guys that
he works with he has like a little crew
or whatever so he has one guy who's in
there two's an electrician and then he
like sneaks up behind Matt because
everybody's sneaking up behind Matt
today I guess so you know what I mean
he's like hey God damn it don't do that
because you know he's a little jumpy so
um so basically the crew member he's the
you know the electrician guy he's going
to like fix the light fixture or
whatever like electricians do and it
sort of zaps him I guess and he goes to
Matt and he's like you know it's like
I've been an electrician for 25 years or
however long it was and he's like I've
never seen any crazy [__] like this it's
like I keep getting electrocuted and
it's [__] and then he didn't really
say that but um he's like yeah and Matt
was on there like the real Matt was on
there and he's like yeah it's like we
kept getting all these crew members it
was kind of like a Summer Wind situation
where it's like we kept having all these
crew members come in and they didn't say
Hey [__] this place we're not gonna work
in here but they did keep like
complaining about stuff like weird [__]
happening in there they didn't really
specify what weird [__] like the
electrician said yeah the electrical was
all [__] up but that's not necessarily
paranormal it might just be it just
happened that's just that just bad
happens bad wiring especially a house
that old yeah but so I don't know I
don't know if the other people were
complaining it's like oh my tools are
missing or like other weird [__] was
happening they didn't really specify but
he did say that there were you know
other crew members working in there that
were complaining about how weird the
house was
so um so then they go back to that
because remember I said the family was
still living at the old house at this
point while they were fixing up the new
one
now this particular I thought this was I
actually kind of liked this little bit
of a misdirect because they did a thing
where Matt wakes up at the old house
like in the middle of the night and he
hears something like out like it sounds
like somebody's like out in the living
room he's like what the [__] is that and
you're thinking oh the ghost like moved
to like the old house it's like it's
pretty haunting you know what I mean but
um but then at April wakes up too and
she's like what the [__] that noise
and then so he goes out in the living
room and then there's like an actual
dude it was an actual dude that like
broke into their house so it wasn't a
ghost but I thought I kind of liked that
they sort of like set it up like it was
a ghost you know what I mean like before
they even went to the haunted house but
it was an actual dude that had broken
into their house nobody got hurt or
anything like that I guess he was just
broken to steal some [__] and when Matt
came out the room was like what the [__]
like he ran out
but um but what that led to was that
basically even though the new house you
know the new old house wasn't done yet
like really only the third floor was
mostly done
um April didn't feel safe in their old
house anymore because obviously they
have a bunch of random [__]
like wandering in this their ceiling
[__] so they're like okay well let's
move into the house even though it's not
done like the third floor is mostly done
we can just live up there while I'm
working on the bottom two floors
so that's what they do
so they said weeks went by uh but it was
kind of difficult like I said April like
works really really long hours and you
know they never really saw each other
because he was always working on the
house and she was always working at
night and blah blah
so then there's a little scene where the
littler kid who was seven who I think is
Brian I thought Chris was the older
teenager but so the little kid is in the
bed this was actually like a pretty good
scene too I thought
and he's in the bed and he hears his
closet door like clicking just slightly
open like not not even open open but it
was just kind of like you know what I
mean like the like the little latch was
coming out
and then he kind of looks over and he
sort of sees the knob turning and he has
like a little flashlight by his bed like
I guess a lot of little kids do and he
like shines it over there and then it
kind of goes out and he's like what the
[__] and he's like back and then he he
goes does the light real quick over
there and then the closet door is wide
open and I'm like oh that was I liked
that that was really well there's
another not a monster in there anything
like that but I just like that the
closet door is just like wide open
suddenly I thought that was really that
was really good
so he also apparently he's heard
giggling as well and at least that's
what they showed on the show
so um because he's seven he screams
bloody murder
and uh so Matt the dad he is gonna run
in there and help him but he Matt said
he couldn't get the door open for a
minute or the door or his bedroom door
closed by itself and he couldn't get it
open like for a minute or two but he
finally does kind of wrench it open and
then he gets into the kid's room and
he's like oh my God there's a monster in
the closet it's like but of course
there's nothing in there I said wouldn't
it be funny if like one time they
actually did that and and he's like
there's a monster in the closet you open
it and there's an actual launcher and
they're like hey but uh yeah they never
do that there was nothing in there
and Matt at this point real Matt he says
um
that the kid they were starting to worry
about him because they're like he had
nightmares all the time and he's he's
like I'm not just talking about we woke
up one time like at night he was waking
up like multiple times a night screaming
his head off because he was apparently
having these horrible nightmares so they
started like worrying about him
and Matt is also starting to suspect
that something weird might be going into
the house because you know when the kid
screamed and he went in there he said
the door his bedroom door very clearly
like closed by itself and like wouldn't
let him open it for like a few minutes
so he's like okay maybe there's
something weird going on
now they said that over the next several
weeks after that
Matt um hasn't really been getting much
good sleep either because remember his
wife is like working at night so she's
not there and there's still like a lot
of construction going on he's like
everyone's just really really stressed
out and tired and everything
and there's one point where he's
downstairs and I guess he kind of like
thinks he sees a person's Shadow like on
the wall or like going up the stairs or
something like that but I guess he
thinks he's just tired of seeing things
or whatever
now uh there's also a scene where he's
kind of like he was like oh I didn't see
that or whatever and then he like
unrolls the the
um the house plans and he's going it's
night time so he's kind of going over to
the window to like look at him and he
puts him up against the window like to
kind of roll them out and then he like
takes it down and then there's a dude
like a ghost dude obviously like
standing outside like of the window like
looking in at him so he's like okay I
guess there's something is really
something weird doing on this [__]
house there's a ghost like standing
there like [__] looking at me
so Matt doesn't tell anybody about this
he's like look man he's like one I
didn't want to scare the little kids and
two like everybody was stressed out
stressed out enough as it is and I want
to tell him there's some ghosty
[__] like hanging out outside
the window so that's not cool
um and then I wrote here by notes I said
they try to do fun family [__] like
making bird houses because they showed
them all sitting on the porch making
birdhouses just for some reason
um and then one night a bit later I
guess April gets woken up one night and
she hears
I guess it was kind of like ghostly kid
voices they kind of sounded like they
were saying mommy mommy or something
like that and she thought it was Brian
like the little kid like calling for her
but she goes in there to check on him
and he's sound asleep so she's been
hearing some weird [__] too
now several nights later this was at
this was also a good scene this actually
had some good scenes in it I thought
that were like pretty creepy
so April I guess she fell asleep on the
couch like in the living room like
watching TV
and on the TV she didn't say she saw
this maybe they were just doing this as
like foreshadowing or whatever but I
guess like the TV was on and then like
it goes all staticky and then like a
little ghost kid comes on the TV like
Mommy Mommy and then it goes like all
staticky again but then she was just
like huh what was that and then she's
like like she just turns it off and like
falls asleep
but then
her um I guess she dozes off and then
her hair like pulls out like a little
Hank of her hair like gets pulled out by
itself and someone starts braiding it
like she's an invisible person I thought
that was really creepy because you would
[__] your pants if you saw that because
it was just like so incongruous yeah
it's not like greatness yeah it's not
like overtly scary but see stuff like
that is way scarier to me than just like
looking at being like ooh killer clown
or whatever she gets up in her hair's
like that and she's trying to shake
she's like what the [__] like it was
like a ghost like touching me well the
weird thing was that she didn't she was
just laying down there like that and
apparently her hair was up like that and
then Matt wakes up and he's like oh I
wonder where she is she must have fallen
asleep downstairs and he goes downstairs
to check on her and he sees it like he
sees her laying on the couch and her
hair is like sticking up like that and
like getting braided by like an
invisible person which yeah yeah like I
said that would be super freaky like if
you saw that in real life [__] like that
is like way scarier to me than overly
scary stuff I don't know why the lead
you to believe it was a ghost of a
little child yeah oh they show a little
kid I think and then it goes yeah
yeah I don't know if he necessarily saw
that I don't think he saw that but I
think they were just sure for show
purposes that it was like a little kid
that was braiding her hair yeah so at
this point you know he tells her it's
like yeah an invisible person was
braiding your hair and that's pretty
freaky so they start kind of comparing
notes on
what they've seen and heard because
they've both seen and heard things so
this was another good one where the dude
actually started to suspect that there
was like a haunting going on and he
wasn't dismissive or anything like that
I mean they pretty much both got on the
same page pretty quickly
um because they had both seen things
so
um they are like okay so they're like
well we need to sort this out and that
was another thing too they they kind of
got right on it
uh I also like that they didn't involve
the church at all
um they just because that's another
thing that they'll usually do but they
didn't they were basically like okay
some paranormal [__] is going on we need
to deal with it so they took the kids to
Grandma's which you know so they
wouldn't be in the way or whatever that
they didn't want them getting scared and
they're like we are gonna they start
doing some research and they said well
maybe we can do this stuff ourselves so
you know burning sage and tell the
ghosts to get the [__] out all that kind
of stuff
um so Matt said that after doing the
whole Research into like how to Siege
the house or whatever which seems like
it wouldn't be that all that difficult
frankly
um he's like well he's gonna do it alone
like while April is at work so he goes
all around the house like saging it or
wherever
and then he goes into the closet room
door thingy like the one that he opened
up you know what I mean like into a
closet that was the hidden room before
the Forgotten essentially
um and he said as soon as he opened that
they kind of had it like like the you
know the wind machine or whatever kind
of like blowing him everything and then
like the door closed by itself behind
him and everything
so he sages in there now he says after
they did the sage everything was cool in
the house for three days like it felt
completely normal nothing creepy nothing
weird anything like that
then they're like three nights after the
sage thing
April wakes up in the middle of the
night saying I think Brian's having a
nightmare and Matt's like um Brian is at
Grandma's house you know is it like that
was Matt's mom they took her they took
the kids there
and then all of a sudden
Ghost Boy appears like by the side of
the bed there's like a ghost boy then
there's like a ghost guy like in the
closet it's just a ghost Lollapalooza
like all up in the [__] and then I think
the bed lifted off the floor too didn't
it yeah I think I think it kind of went
up a little bit because I think I didn't
see that the first time because I was
like writing stuff down and I I guess it
happened really quick but then like you
know how sometimes before they go to the
commercial break and then they'll kind
of like re-show like little second clips
of all the [__] that happened up to now
and then they showed like the bed coming
off the floor I'm like wait did that
happen I guess so so the bed lifted off
the floor and then one of the ghosts
apparently started strangling April like
because she was like ah like that you
know what I mean so yeah it just [__]
popped off is what I'm saying there's
like you know ghost child ghost adult
all kind of people
uh and again these people were like not
[__] around Matt's like yeah we're
out uh they went to a hotel you know
what I mean these are probably
so many smart people
from the bunny because I know it's like
even if there was ghosts and stuff but
yeah it's like [__] good hundred
dollars a night minimum right that's
what I'm saying decent hotel not you
could be a new damn Bell
picking up picking up [__] pubic
hairs
he crusty underwear cockroaches yeah
just splatter all over [__] with the
blue [__] blue light watch another
dirty room if you don't know that's what
we're talking about that YouTube channel
um but you know don't don't watch it
while you're eating I I wouldn't advise
it because I've done it before and then
I'm like oh why did I do this I always
forget
um but yeah so they go to a hotel which
like I said if you're good on them
so they're like well now what the [__]
do we do but they had a friend of a
friend
who I guess recommended a Paranormal
Investigator and at first they said well
the Paranormal Investigator I know this
Paranormal Investigator his name's Bill
and I'm like oh God this isn't Bill Bean
again is it like the coming in with the
jesusy stuff but it wasn't it was a
different guy it was a guy named Bill
Spencer and he runs a place I don't know
if it's still around or not
but it's called Insight paranormal
so it's bill and his nephew Jeremy they
founded it and apparently according to I
mean they were both on the show too but
uh according to Matt and April these
guys are like super super scientific
they came with all the stuff and they're
trying to you know and they're like we
were very skeptical of this because it
sounded kind of crazy but you know
obviously we're gonna go in there and
see what we can do so they're gonna
spend the night in the house alone
because like I said Matt and April are
staying at a hotel and the kids are at
Grandma's
so they're going to go in there and set
up all the [__] and see what they can
see you know what I mean they set up all
their cameras and EVP [__] and all that
so um it's so funny to me like these
early episodes of Haunting they always
every single time they say EVP they
always have to say electronic voice
phenomenon and like say what it is it's
like nowadays everyone knows everybody
is at EVP is but they've back then they
had it like explain it every time for
for people that didn't know what it was
so they so I even put EVP to find
um so the Spencers visit uh the house
like several times and like stay over
there at night and like keep track of
everything filming things and recording
things
said that they got over a hundred EVPs
this is more than they'd ever gotten in
any case they'd ever done previous to
this uh apparently these ghosts are real
[__] talkative
um they determined
that they thought that half of the EVPs
that they got were residual as in you
know just like a recording of something
that happened there and like nothing
like it like it didn't respond to their
in questions intelligently but the other
half did seem to be responding to their
questions intelligently at least
according to them and like I said on the
show they on the haunting they never
show they never play the real stuff so I
don't really know
uh they said the most significant one
they got was a very very strong male
voice saying I want you out
they also um after April asked them oh
did you hear a little boy's voice
because she's like I'm pretty sure that
I've heard a little boy you know around
the house and he's like oh funny you
should say that because
um he played the little EVP and there
was like a some kids voices saying stuff
like Mommy or whatever that was saying
um now they thought that according to
all of the EVPs and [__] like that they
got that they thought that there was at
least a dozen ghost children in the
house when I was on the Facebook page
earlier for the book which is called
harvesting Shadows
um they said that there was 21 ghosts in
there
so
I don't know I don't know how you can
counter them all they counted them yeah
by the voices I guess yeah I guess like
they all had different voices but they
said yeah there's at least a dozen
Spirit kids in here maybe more
I'm always suspect to EVP stuff
especially if they don't play it
now Steve Maris said it's a reality he
said he's got some good ones you know
Jenny's worked with him I've talked to
him a lot doing some of his books and
during his during his investigations he
said that he he said that he believed
that they were residual but he also did
say sometimes they would interact also
but not extensively
I've heard some of the best ones in it
man I think it's open to interpretation
you know
that might be just
some kind of a noise from outside and
you're like tea leaves you're reading
into it kind of like backwards masking
you know on records Aces scared the [__]
out of me that we used to have to listen
to them the radio to hear about the
church by the damn Satan [__] satanic
masking and they play the [__] [__]
backwards of your hair and stand up on
it
before you really knew what the hell was
going on you know so I can Stairway to
Heaven and [__] so it might be something
like that
you record some stuff and then they it's
never normal volume they were always
really turning the volume up to listen
real closely to stuff man you might go
pick up anything and you're just kind of
interpreting what it said
there's been a few of them on some of
these girls programs that they've
actually played
that did sound creepy
the girl who is uh in Paranormal Witness
for the uh the Poltergeist [__]
episode about cat and that was the name
of that Poltergeist I think wasn't it
called cat or is it just called
Poltergeist I think it was like episode
one or two
she sent me a a
she said don't release this but look
this is what the Poltergeist put on my
[__] cell phone phone messages and it
just sounded like a temp get to get to
get to get to get to get to get you it
sounded like kitty kitty kitty kitty
kitty and it was writing the word cat
everywhere
it was creepy
because
listen to her whole story it kind of
matched up a similar to Bob hers was
actually stronger a little bit
but uh I forgot her name I used to have
her on my friends list she's on there
somewhere
but she didn't want to come to the show
so you want to talk about it she's like
nah I'm done talking about it I don't
blame her yeah
but well I mean I got a kid now and
she's done talking about that [__] yeah
I mean the thing about EVPs I've heard
maybe like one or two that I thought oh
that's pretty creepy most of the other
ones literally could be anything yeah
and a lot of times like especially the
ones that they put on like the ghost
shows that they'll play on there they're
like listen it says blah blah blah and
I'm like that's not what I heard it's
like in fact I have no idea what that
said it just sounded like more normal
yeah right that could be anything you're
reading and then they're like no it says
this and I'm like does it I don't that
doesn't sound like that to me but I mean
I know I'm kind of deaf but I'm not bad
deaf okay every now and then they'll
show you one that does sound pretty
compelling but
and there's room for error there man
it's open to interpretation well the
thing about that and that's kind of why
I'm so skeptical about this haunting
stuff is because
there's literally a million things that
it could be before you extrapolate
forward to like oh the afterlife exists
yeah because that's kind of a big thing
I mean that's a that's a big thing you
have to prove I'm just saying yeah that
you have to eliminate all of the
possible things that it could be and
there are so many possible things that
it could be that I just feel like I
don't know if you'd ever get to a point
where you know what I'm saying not me
I'm totally convinced that in in
afterlife so I've had near-death
experiences like in um Out of Body
Experience spontaneous uh Out of Body
Experience before
um and there is another realm you know
where you're out of your body but you're
still conscious and there are other
things in that in there there are other
things there with you that are also
conscious uh of different levels of
sophistication I've seen Poltergeist
I've been in a bad house before no I'm
absolutely convinced Jenny's seen some
Poltergeist mild activity
um but she kinda
discounts it some for some reason like
it didn't happen but she is the one that
woke up no that's no that's not what I
said I had to [__] go get it I'm just
said Poltergeist Poltergeist phenomena
yeah is not the same thing as ghost
phenomena like I'm not saying that's
what I mean but out of beauty you don't
need to put you don't need deposit in
afterlife for Poltergeist stuff to be at
least according to the the
parapsychologist definition of what
causes Poltergeist but there's another
way you can look at it
that bad house there was something in it
but nothing ever moved I couldn't
[__] prove anything and other people
were the same they just as bad feeling
but let's say
there is something in a house and it can
move some things
and maybe even be able to speak or
say some kind of basic communication
just real vague an apparition or
something that's still that would be a
ghost okay but that still doesn't mean
much about afterlife stuff that might be
an image of the past okay something kind
of ingrained in the in that area in the
space time and you picked it up and you
saw something that happened a long time
ago that person it that person's soul
may not be in that ghost that you saw
that person's soul may be long gone dead
maybe maybe it doesn't exist anymore
yeah I mean another realm if I'm gonna
believe in ghosts I would believe more
in that that it was just kind of like a
leftover Trace yeah like a remnant of
something of something that's not
intelligent or right more like a a
mirage of the past or so an echo from
the grave [__]
God damn [__] episodes
they're all called Echoes from the grave
well I think well there was one called
that I think we talked about it yeah and
then the parapsychologists these guys
are ghosts would be called a residual a
residual haunting something just left
over the the the soul isn't there
anymore but
it's kind of like a a three-dimensional
audio and visual recording of something
that happened a long time ago in the era
yeah especially if it was something like
really traumatic yeah which like I said
I'm not sure I entirely believe that but
that seems a lot more likely to me than
yeah it's more likely more likely with
you know with this say quantum physics
or something that yeah you saw The
Apparition you heard its voice it said
something
chances are it would be more okay so
what are we talking about we're talking
about like a damn shadowy Quantum figure
that somehow conf somehow confirms to or
conforms to react uh to to physics or
quantum physics maybe and that image was
actually there moving around
that would be kind of inefficient it'd
be more efficient if somehow a part of
your mind accessed the past and it was
so strong you visually saw it you know
but it wasn't there if you were to take
a photograph you wouldn't see anything
and maybe maybe if another person was
with you maybe they wouldn't have seen
it just you saw it might have been an
image directly into your mind
from the from yeah so that kind of [__]
is like more likely it's weird but
that's more likely to me because it
would be more efficient than having a
construct a 3D moving
ghost [__] image you know what I mean
and to move [__] air molecules to
make a sound you know what I mean it's
more efficient if it just put that
impression in your mind and you
experienced it
yeah because the human mind can do all
kinds of [__] and it experiences stuff
that doesn't really happen like all the
time so so it might be more like just a
mental effect a warping of your
consciousness
and you saw a part of the past you got a
message from something or something that
no longer exists yeah in your space time
exists in another place at another time
and it spoke to you from across time
and something like that
telling you some [__] from some [__] I'm
telling you some [__] yeah
I'm gonna talk to you from a from across
the seas of time they never really tell
you anything all that cool though it's
real mundane [__] get out you know that
kind of and I'm just like really but it
might make sense if it's something
that's generated by emotions maybe it
might just be usually real Primal and
simple
I guess
yeah that's the thing it's like you
think if it was like intelligent ghosts
they would like actually tell you like
yeah how to find the secrets of the
universe and [__] like that because like
oh we know those now but no they just
say [__] like get out of here get out of
here this is my house
that man killed me that kind of [__]
Zach says oh wow Sophie left already
yeah yeah she was only really here for
three days yeah she came on Thursday
night right she came on Thursday night
and Tom just dropped her off at the
airport like a couple hours ago yeah
yeah and she's going back
um
Zach says I'm imagining Tom is one of
the scientists at the end of The Entity
freeze it freezing the ghost yeah I'm
gonna freeze the [__] out of me making
the ghost popsicle yeah I can't believe
they did that at the end of that
freezing put a condom on him
he was raping them women you know just
for the condom on before he gets out
maybe he does maybe they should chop off
his little ghost pain yeah you can't
it's invisible it's invisible
the blade passes
don't question my [__] imagination
why not I don't know you question my
imagination all the time might come up
with all kind of crazy [__] you're like
that couldn't happen I'm like yeah I
know
but uh but yeah
so yeah where was I okay so a dozen
Spirit children or more right
now uh so again like April and Matt are
smart they're just like okay we don't we
don't need this [__] nonsense okay
and it's like um we're gonna we're gonna
move to another house yeah like they
didn't [__] around
um but this was actually kind of nice of
them I thought and you don't really um a
lot a lot of families don't really say
this but they said well we wanted to get
a new house but they said we didn't want
to sell the old one because we didn't
just want because we knew the house was
kind of [__] up and we didn't want to
like fob the problem off on somebody
else so we wanted to make sure that the
house was
good like that all the ghosts were gone
and [__] like that before we'd actually
sell it so I'm like well that's nice of
you anyway
so
um basically they go to talk to a
realtor because they're like look we're
looking for another house and she's like
oh that Victorian that you loved so much
didn't work out and they're like
uh yeah it's a little bit haunted like
um in fact so haunted that we can't live
in it and she's like you know matter of
fact I know someone who is a real estate
broker whose name was Debbie White and
she was a clairvoyant and she said that
she could clear haunted houses they're
like well maybe I mean maybe she can
help you so like call her up
so they call her up so the next day
Debbie
goes into the house and I kind of
laughed because she
like it was just like the normal looking
actors like playing her but she had this
look of such determination like on her
face as she was walking at the front so
like she's gonna go [__] deal with
some ghosts right now [__] like
she has she looks like so serious and
she's just ready to [__] do it and I
don't know why that made me laugh so
hard but it's it so it's like she goes
into the house and does her thing and
like feels around or whatever
and then she comes back and tells April
and Matt
that what the problem is in their house
is that there was once a Mormon see I
told you Mormons were going to come into
this [__] at some point there was some
Mormon uh polygamist in there who had a
bunch of wives and consequently a bunch
of kids and they all lived in this big
house
now apparently
um the renovation on the hidden closet
was what caused the ghosts to like bust
out like what caused the Paranormal
outbreak if you want to call it that is
secret place that's like his secret
place yeah she's like oh the closet is
evil and sick and blah blah
um she said that he was like torturing
molesting whatever uh the kids in that
room and maybe that's why it was closed
off
like I said I don't know if that's true
or not she could have just think about
it right out of her ass they're talking
about an era that'd be over a hundred
years ago that's what I mean there's
really kind of no way to check that yeah
and how many people have been living in
that house I bet you [__] dozens and
dozens of dozens of families have lived
in that house they haven't been [__]
opening that door and going into the
so-called secret [__] room I I ain't
buying it
I ain't buying it that was the story The
psychics tend to make up stories
oh wow because you told tell me you're
having a problem now I have to figure
out where the problem's coming for you
know that weird room that you found yeah
that it's that
you know and this is Salt Lake City's
Mormons we know what they're doing you
know how you know what they're like
that's what they're [__] that's what
she's doing well yeah you're gonna go
with the most likely scenario because
the thing about it is that it's [__]
even though a lot of the so-called
psychics on on this show and on other
paranormal shows they will make a point
of coming out and saying oh I always
tell the families like not to tell me
anything like that I find that is
probably not true I mean I imagine that
when the family if you you know for
whatever reason if you have some kind of
paranormal like problem in your house
and you have to end up calling a
Paranormal Investigator or a psychic or
whatever
um I'm sure you're gonna give them a
little background information like
before you come out there and they can
take that and completely fabricate like
a whole [__] thing around it if you
notice in any of these cases the case
goes along kind of normal lines normal
[__] lines which is strange
occurrences weird phenomenon then a
psychic gets involved and all of a
sudden it's [__] worse now now
there's [__] demons you gotta
criticisms [__] there's elephants
hiding on top of the [__] in the
Attic there's just any [__] thing
there's all kind of murders there's a
prostitution yeah salacious details
bestiality all kinds of [__] weird
[__] as soon as the psychic shows up you
know I mean there's what's there a
bestiality
no there should be though
story is a huge Dobermans and [__] being
uncircumcised Dobermans [__] you know
good dog dudes attacking women with them
ride that red rocket [__] [__] like
that but it's always the always the
[__] it's always yeah
God fetish scene you know
we're aware of this we were shocking
not about Red Rockets specifically but
we were talking hit it with a red rocket
finally but you know I was just
I just really skeptical of Psychics you
can always notice the pattern is as soon
as the psychic shows yeah all hell
breaks loose yeah when it was really
just kind of like a a mild mild
disturbances that were disturbing people
you know
yeah sometimes I think people just want
to get validated that they're not crazy
it's like I you know there is weird [__]
going on here but a psychic does and I'm
not saying that all of them are
necessarily doing it cynically or
anything like I think a lot of them do
actually believe that they're sensitive
or whatever but I do kind of feel like
what they're doing is they're coming in
and they're taking the kind of crumbs of
narrative that the family is giving them
and then they're just kind of like
weaving it into a story into a story um
and which I think a lot of times maybe
like the people want that because it's
like oh well this is it it kind of like
puts it in a box and like gives it an
explanation that they can get a handle
on other than it just being a bunch of
random paranormal activity that doesn't
mean anything because that's the way
math Mountain was me Lois red [__]
oh we didn't know what we didn't know
what it meant not until the very end I
started to suspect but there was no
narrative to it right which kind of
makes it weirder you know like why is
this yeah because it had no reason for
doing anything but it did why did it
stack those [__] books yeah it didn't
mean anything yeah why did it make that
smiley face out of [__] hand towels
why did it do this why did it it it's
just doing [__] yeah it doesn't know why
it's doing it it's just a subconscious
mind doing it [__] using
psychokinesis
[__] with you but it's evading all
[__] you're trying to figure it out
and it's foiling your investigation you
know it just it doesn't want you to know
what it is that's why I'm kind of more
likely to believe like the episodes that
are just like random [__] yeah and
nobody comes in later and says oh the
end that comes up with this like
elaborate narrative about it something
ran out of Hollywood impressive crimes
something that should have been known
about in the in the local area yeah this
person kept abducting all the school
girls from the local Catholic school and
pimping them out to the priests and
everybody was involved and even the
mayor knew you know what year is this
you know oh uh 1820 you know it's like
they had newspapers then you'd think
somebody would have found that out
absolutely been well well known you know
um chant I'm not saying it's a fake case
chances are though it was just random
strange phenomenon and that they never
really knew what it was
you had a second come in and try to make
an explanation yeah
maybe they thought they were telling the
truth but man the pattern I think
sometimes they do I'm not willing to go
just across the board and say oh they're
all just like scam artists yeah on
purpose
I'm gonna say that I do think they're
scam artists but not I don't think a lot
of them actually think that there's
games you ever have any [__] like this
going on in your house I do not
recommend bringing psychics in there no
that's just gonna [__] up though that's
just gonna muddy I would not even bring
any priests they don't they're not
they're not ready see that's why I liked
this episode because they did not even
it didn't even come up right right the
first thing they did was like well we'll
Sage the house ourselves and it's like
that works for a couple days but then
they're like okay well we need to pair
them with us yeah and they just went
straight to that no
a parapsychologist maybe
see I would rather that I mean you know
don't get anybody from one of those
[__] Grateful Dead drum circles or
anything about them
maybe somebody if you're Central
American or South America maybe somebody
that knows about Santeria or condom play
macumba Brazil
they're they're familiar with [__]
ghosts and spirits that's part of their
religion
and uh they may be able to appease it
with offerings
kind of like a Taoist priest might in
that one episode of [__] yeah the one
with the Tarantulas right and the woman
that didn't like this place now it may
appease these so-called spirits
not because the spirits were appeased if
they might appease the spirits because
it settles your mind and you feel better
about the situation so you're able to
cope with it better
and you're not feeding this with some
kind of psychic energy to keep the ball
rolling you're relaxed so it kind of
dissipates yeah that's probably why I
think that's the much more like
explanation that's why exorcism
sometimes do appear to work I don't
think demons are real I just think that
if you really believe in them and you so
you have somebody in there that
supposedly has the authority to exercise
the demon then
if you really believe it then maybe then
it'll work it might work
but it does that doesn't mean demons are
real right that means that the human
mind is a very strange and powerful
force yeah you know what I mean you can
convince yourself of pretty much
anything oh I can guarantee you
with what I've seen especially starting
with Poltergeist faith has a lot to do
with things yes
I was a man I was a boy of faith I was
religious I believed in um things like
ghosts
uh said and I believed in things like
psychic abilities
and that allows it to happen I I knew
back then
I I I believed back then because I was
told it was real
you know and I was seeing it on in
movies that I believed
you know yeah so I was just like yeah
that happens
you can make it happen
yeah
but like you said that's kind of like
like I said that's more of like a human
mind thing yeah like it's basically the
force what they're talking about yeah
it's the yin and yang abilities you know
it's like going all the way back to
uh Buddhism and you know taoism to a
certain extent too so yeah
the the power of faith in the mind yeah
yeah I mean you if you really [__]
believe something I mean it could help
some some crazy [__] Could Happen yeah
you know
but uh within within limits right right
yeah I'm not saying you can do anything
you can't like [__] fly off a cliff
right like that because that's not
because humans that that doesn't work
it's gonna be more things like dreaming
true or uh maybe being being able to
affect the throw or the role of a dice
or
um yeah nothing major right having
moving an object an object just appears
out of nowhere that you were thinking of
that kind of stuff but you didn't
actually see it move it just it's just
there now
um you look away from something that you
were looking at and it falls just it's
going to be things like that
Zach said oh I remember this episode
it's the one where all the [__] is
flying around at the end and everyone's
screaming yeah um it's funny because
this episode is like pretty good and
like pretty low-key up until the end and
then the end goes way over the top
um which it was very much like the end
of poltergeist like but I just thought
it was really funny so we were watching
it last night and I was like two at a
[__] tangina impression from
Poltergeist because that's what it
reminded me of but I'll get into that in
a second but yeah so the psychic
basically says yeah there's a Mormon
polygamist in here and and they did make
sure like one of them to point out it's
like oh well didn't the Mormons like ban
polygamy or something I'm like well not
all of them but you know what I mean
because that's what we did a whole show
about that they've worn Jefferson and
all those guys they went off into like
factions and stuff yeah some of them
still wanted to do the mainstream Church
doesn't do this but yeah that's that's
still not yeah they say they don't I
don't know they got people that aren't
in that church doing that that's true
whole boob Arabs and [__] yeah Tom wants
a boo bear him I got a boob hair
you never can't tell what it could
happen the uh
Tom Keith he's hoping
[Laughter]
like all these all these big tittied
women are suddenly gonna like appear
behind us one of these just stick all
this [__]
[Laughter]
where's that silly boob harem was
[__] that was Zach's idea that was
Zach's terminology I've adopted that I
was like yeah yeah that's a good idea
Zach a gay man thought that up that's
crazy gay man think gay men think of the
best stuff yeah
yeah that's right you should be straight
man that's great man Zach says you're
welcome you should be straight coming up
ah
can access feels good to finally catch
him live again Long Live Jenny and Tom
fingers crossed from your from your lips
to God's ears if I believe the guy which
I don't block Rock said is this an old
one this episode yeah it's season three
like I said for true we're trying to do
all the old ones and then we'll get into
the silly like newer ones newer you know
what I mean
so yeah uh molesty Mormons right so she
says okay I can I can Cleanse This House
oh I can do that [__]
um so she does it in February 2006. so
as I said this the time period here is
like very constrained because I think
they first bought the house in 2003 so I
guess they lived there off and on for
like three years but so the psychic
comes in they're not I don't think
they're living in the house at this
point the family I think they had bought
another place but they haven't sold the
old one yet
so she's gonna go in there and and
cleanse it and uh Bill and Jeremy the
guys from inside paranormal they go in
there and like record the whole thing of
course they didn't show any of it on
this particular show I don't know if you
can see it somewhere else
um one thing they did I don't think I've
seen them do this on another show was
kind of like she had like salt water
like in a spray bottle and was like
spraying that all over the place and I
was like oh like kind of like ghost
Febreze or some [__] like that she was
like spraying it all over because I was
like oh is that the smell of sanctity oh
no it's just salt water oh well
oh I wonder if you could just like put
salt water in spray jars and like Market
it like as a at a substantial markup
like for ghost purposes yeah maybe well
because you know how they do you know
that [__] thing what that what is
that thing called but it just basically
goes through radio channels randomly and
they're like oh ghosts are talking to me
I'm like yeah that's just a radio
station it's just scan it's words like
popping out every now and then and
you're just reading into it like it's
you know paradolia or whatever you call
it I said that's what that is it's just
a radio scanner that's all it is but
they but I don't even know how much they
charge for those but I'm like yeah they
can sell those to prepare I imagine yeah
I'm like man that was a good scam I wish
I thought of that but maybe I can do the
salt water bottle thing I'll just put
salt water in there just please they
call it like [__] ghost be gone or
some [__]
um but yeah so she basically says to
Matt well the closet is the worst place
obviously that you opened up and because
um you [__] uh the ghosts hiding place
he's mad at you and has been like
[__] with everything so he's like
maybe put some of the old boards like
because I guess he still had some of the
old pieces and old boards and stuff like
down in the basement and he's like kind
of put those back the way they were so
like maybe the ghost won't be so mad at
you
and then they did this thing where they
all did they had all these candles and
whatnot and then they went down the
basement to get some of the old boards
and Debbie like starts talking to you
know the ghost kids like the imaginary
kids or whatever and then they do this
funny scene where there's all this like
um like ghostly giggling or whatever and
then she walks into this dark
crawl space type thing like underneath
the stairs and she crawls under there
and then they do a thing where
everybody's like goes really quiet and
they're all just like Debbie are you
okay I'm like she's [__] fine it's
like they're just doing that for the
show knock it off it's like yeah she
just walked in there and went into
another dimension she's just right there
so yeah so because I put Debbie
disappears not really though so she
comes out and then all she says is all
is as it should be she's all very like
wise and everything
and then she says they all had candles
and they basically
did a good little ghost parade where
they LED all the ghost kids allegedly up
to from the basement I get I don't know
what the basement had to do with
anything but because they didn't mention
that but they were down in the basement
it looked like but so they lead all the
ghost kids up to the closet room
and I guess that was where just like in
Poltergeist the closet that was where
the the way station between the
dimensions I'm assuming so they have to
take the kids up there and then kind of
like dissipate the energy so all the
ghost kids are falling now this was the
funniest part and I think this is part
that Zach was talking about up to this
point this has been a fairly low-key
episode right I mean it had did had some
jump scares and just had some
apparitions and stuff but it was like
pretty low-key
but at this point they go up there and
they get like the door to the closet
room and the psychic opens it and it
full on go you know the scene in
Poltergeist where they open the closet
it's like and like all the light and
like the wind machine and if everybody's
hair is blowing and everybody has to
yell at each come on
we're just like that and then this is
the best part and then the psychic she
couldn't shoot like the wind was like
that she's like
and then she had to crawl it is like she
had a crawl on first to give a walk in
there I'm like oh my God this is [__]
hilarious but yeah so they made a huge
huge deal and I was like they bought a
wind machine and they're gonna use the
[__] basically so it's just like this
bright light in the white man
it was like I know but that well that
part was funny
that [__] went up in the air it's
pretty good and they left they left on
the [__] Moon beams remember that and
disappeared off into the clouds yeah
it's like yeah all the little molested
children flew away
hey we're going to go to hell
where we will know
what I did
yes the Mormon dad went with him and
he's like yeah you're right I'm gonna
follow you performance
we pick on everybody we pick it up I've
known lots of more Mormons are good
people
but yeah it's just uh the whole thing
was just very dramatic and it just like
made me laugh and it reminded me very
much of I kept like saying lines from
Poltergeist the whole time because
that's really that's you could tell
that's where they got the inspiration
from
um so they go into they all go into the
closet room they all battle the wind and
everything with the candles and and all
that and then
Matt takes the um I guess it was like a
like a board or something like that from
the old closet that he still had and he
takes it and he's like push and like
breaks the window with it and I'm like
now you gotta fix that I mean you know
and then the evil ghost is there and
this is what we were talking about this
actually was pretty decent special
effects for 2006 2007 whenever this was
because the the evil ghost is like oh
yeah yeah in his face and his face like
like it's all like light in his mouth
and his eyes and everything and then it
starts kind of like disintegrating and
I'm like oh that was pretty red yeah and
I think even Sophie said oh that was
pretty good special effects for how old
this is yeah
for how anxious it's like oh my God this
is like before my thanks [__] when
dinosaurs there yeah she's gonna be
listening to this episode
because she watched it with us because
she's like oh I wanna because she hadn't
seen them in such a long time and she's
like I want to watch it with you guys so
like I can know what you're talking
about but yeah so she watched this
watched it with us last night but uh
yeah so what we never forget like how
old we are like around her she doesn't
I don't know she doesn't make a huge
thing about it but sometimes she does
like mention something I took her to the
club
and I showed her some of the people that
look we know and told him how old she
was she was [__] amazed she was
amazed though
how how good some of these old people
look nowadays
she was talking to Will and and [__]
Will's all he's he's a ex-military black
dude is a friend of mine and he's all
Goth out and [__] and and I and I go how
old do you think he is and she goes how
old are you he goes I'm 60. yeah she's
like no [__]
nobody believes these he doesn't look
sexy no he doesn't look 60. he looks
about 50. maybe yeah he's on test too he
looks like I mean he looks like a really
really well preserved yeah he married a
a white chick on active duty she's a
military army doctor I think she's a
major
yeah and he was enlisted he was he was a
spec four like me so it's like a
corporal's Marion [__]
did they get married or they just shack
up I think they're married aren't they I
don't know I think they did okay I don't
know if they ever did I thought they
were engaged engaged that's what it was
but I'm not sure that they ever like
yeah did the deed you know what I'm
saying I don't remember them doing that
you know who just got engaged Andy who
Andy
which Andy you know Andy
Williams yeah yeah Will Zach's that Andy
yeah yeah Andy even though that was like
a long time ago right yeah Bennett Andy
Bandit man whoops we just said our whole
name yeah she's she's I think a few
olders a few years older than me yeah
and her boyfriend is maybe 30 something
yeah he's a lot younger yeah but they
yeah she's cute I saw it on she's cute
on Facebook yeah she's uh isn't that
funny I'm gonna say this [__] that
you're gonna forget she's a cute old
lady
yeah we don't really imagine our friends
as being old they're just like a god of
people that we've known for [__] what
[__] almost 15 years in some cases
well yeah I mean we were talking about
this with Sophie too because it's like
it doesn't really occur to us that it's
like oh that's just so and so like when
it doesn't occur to us that they're like
[__] 60 years old yeah
well some of them don't look some of
them don't look like it and they're
still out clubbing and dancing and stuff
so it's like I don't really worry about
it it's a girl we know who's just
killer dancer dresser fantastic [__]
figure not an ounce of fat otter
who can pull guys in their [__] late
20s and early 30s and
she's late 40s you wouldn't know by
looking at her though
yeah and then there was this one chick
she's a little Cuban American chick from
here and she's maybe like five feet tall
I haven't seen her in about three or
four years
she's way older than me she's pushing
60. she looks great though we saw her on
Saturday we hadn't seen her in a while
yeah then we saw her she looks exactly
the same yeah so she's happy to see us
and I said how you been you know this
and that this is where's all you little
boys because she would show up with
these young dudes
jog she's like 50 and it wouldn't you
don't know it by looking at him they
look punk rock outfits and Goth outfits
and
um she's a little
Cuban American Gothic and just show up
with these guys that are like in their
late 20s and early 30s and it says
where's your little boys and he goes I
married one
how old is he he's 35.
yes I've been made two years and I was
like no [__] you [__] cougars well of
course
she's bad
she's off in my life probably weighs
about 90 pounds that's what we'll talk
about that on the side track show
Saturday but I was like we went we
hadn't been to Barbarella on a Saturday
night a while and it's like I forgot how
fun it well I mean we saw almost
everybody I saw people I haven't seen it
like but she probably pushing 60.
no you can't tell
if you see her from 20 feet in a club in
that outfit you think you're seeing it
looking at a person look like you're
looking at a girl about 30 35 maybe you
would never ever think pushing 60. never
but yeah so uh what happened so the evil
ghost disintegrates well no I was like
yeah super funny
um Zach says Jenny you need help sister
I was nine when this episode came out
well it doesn't seem I mean in a lot of
ways it's weird like maybe you'll know
like when you start getting as old as we
are but um
it's like it seems like a long time ago
like whenever the [__] this came out
2008 or whenever it was that definitely
does seem like a long time ago like when
I think about it but then on the other
hand it kind of doesn't you know at the
time me and Jen met each other we met in
2009 or 2010 yeah something like that
and that's that seems like yesterday
it seems like yesterday but it also
seems like a million years ago just
depends on is that weird
well it seems like both at the same time
as soon as you pass 35 a year just
[__] goes by everything starts
speeding up speeds up real fast and then
you'll be like oh remember the other day
when you did this and that that was like
that was seven years ago
I hit 38 man I thought it was the end of
the [__] world dude I'm almost 40.
you know what I mean and the next thing
you know is [__] 43 and I felt about
the same I was like looking in the
mirror to look about the it doesn't
really change to be honest yeah I kind
of I've heard that from a lot of people
as they get older they're like I still
feel like a young person like you did
because you still think like he's you
don't change significantly it doesn't
hit it doesn't hit men until late 40s
with that [__] andrena Paul Andrew
Andrew pause [__] but just go on test
and you'll just continue to go I
recommend I'm a great I'm a men's rights
activist and a [__] I tell you
[__]
do what you you lose your testosterone
just inject it [__] all your [__]
will come back you get your religion but
now if you've been neglected it for a
long time and you're [__] 40 50
pounds overweight it's gonna take a long
time a couple years but it'll come
your body will respond to training
you'll feel a lot better
Zach said didn't the psychic lady in
this one have old person jowls and a
really ugly hairdo
um I don't remember not that I remember
she was just kind of like a skinny yeah
like you know older lady I did I don't
remember her leg being fat or Jolly or
anything particularly
it wasn't anything that stood out
um so yeah so the evil ghost
disintegrates all the little molested
ghost children go and like you know
disintegrate into the air or whatever
and then they the stuff that they used
in the ceremony so I'm assuming like the
old pieces of the house and the candles
and stuff I think they buried those on
the property so the evil ghost can't
come back because apparently that's how
that works I'm not really never really
heard that before but okay
um and apparently no more activity was
reported vents forth uh Matt finished
fixing the house up and because no more
activity was that they felt safe selling
it but um they did not move back in
there which like I thought that was kind
of interesting because usually well like
I said a lot of the families are kind of
like well we couldn't move because all
of our money was tied up in it which
like I said you know
it's it's not easy to just kind of move
but these this family they seem to at
least have they didn't seem rich but at
least they had the resources to be like
hey we don't we want another house we
don't want to live in this [__] and we
can go stay in a hotel and stuff because
they did not [__] around you know
they're basically like we're gonna deal
with this [__] and then we're getting
the [__] out of here you know what I
mean they didn't like they didn't dick
around with it which I thought was kind
of interesting
so they did buy another house uh and as
I mentioned if you would care to read it
uh it's not it's not free on Kindle
unlimited unfortunately I think it's
6.99 uh and obviously there's also a
print version I think it came out in
2016 or 2017. uh and it's called
harvesting Shadows by Douglas burchill
now I think just based on the blurb
that I think it's a novel but it's based
on this story like a true story
I think I'm not entirely sure if that's
the case that was the impression I got
like just from reading about it that it
was like a novelization so take of that
which you will
you know just take it take it with a
spray bottle full of salt then I'm gonna
start selling as good pretty soon
it was a good paranormal investigation a
good old episode though
yeah and this is another one that
I just I it didn't stand out in the Run
but when I went back and watched it
because when I was reading the episode
list on Wikipedia I was like oh I kind
of don't remember that one and we
haven't covered that one so let's do
that one and I was watching I was like
well this is a decent episode too all
these like first
we've done we've talked about a couple
that were sort of
yeah but even the most meh you know
first four season episodes are like
better than some of the later ones and
it's not so much the the later ones I
don't think it was so much them being
boring is that a lot of them were just
like too stupid and really just like too
outlandish and they were just too much
they were trying to be too much like a
horror movie like they were too much had
narratives and too many jumpscares and
[__] yeah it was like dudes fighting
most of werewolves and I don't you know
it was like all that kind of like
Witchcraft and all this like it was just
they got crazy and I get that they were
running out of stories and they're like
look you know they're still paying us to
make this show so we need like something
on here so might as well just and I
think most people are watching these
just like you would watch a horror movie
so they're not really worried about how
watching them ironically right so
they're not really worried about it it's
like oh this is like super because I
think if you made a show that's was very
like scientifically rigorous like about
it like nobody would watch it because
it'd be like boring you know what I mean
so yeah that's what it is all right so
uh that was the end of that episode like
I said it's season three episode six if
you would like to watch it even though I
just spoiled it please tell me what you
thought of like the end where they
opened the door and like the wind and
she had to crawl in the closet stuff
like that because that just like really
made me laugh but um I was just laughing
my ass off but I think since we didn't
do a movie review on Sunday I think we
should probably do one tomorrow
so we just gotta watch a movie tonight
yeah okay well like I said all I have to
do is like run and take a shower and
then I'm just gonna do uh we can either
do Blackhawk Down because Victor sent us
that we'll check how long it is if it's
really long then we'll have to pick
something else but I think the movie
because a couple of y'all have talked
about Megan that new horror movie
um I think it's streaming for free on
peacock for a limited amount of time
let's watch that first because right not
totally awake and I might fall asleep
right and I have been wanting to see
that and a couple of y'all have like
recommended it and I was just like so
I'd rather see Megan because I don't I
mean hopefully we can watch if we can't
watch it then I'll pick something else
that's like kind of short but you know
I'll check shutter or something like
that but that was what I was planning on
because I think it's available on
peacock for like a limited time like for
free so we can watch that tonight and
then we can talk about that tomorrow and
then on Wednesday night is our main show
and we're gonna do I've been wanting to
do a show about this in a long time
we're gonna do the mysterious
disappearance of Louis Le Prince if you
don't know who that is he's actually the
real [__] that invented the
movie camera no it was not Thomas Edison
and uh this guy
mysteriously disappeared and maybe
Thomas Edison was involved so uh but
it's a it's a really like interesting
story so that's what we're gonna do the
show about Wednesday night so hopefully
you guys can join us uh tomorrow and
Wednesday night for the live streams and
thank you everybody for dropping by and
hanging out with us like you always do
and we'll see you guys again tomorrow
probably good night